I thought just for a bit of a change of
pace we could look at one of the classic
algorithms right uh binary search um
binary search is something you learn
about perhaps slightly earlier in your
career maybe as you know an
undergraduate or maybe even you know in
school um but it's super important and I
think also really interesting because it
illustrates some of the things you need
to think about as a software developer
about how to make things faster and how
to use things appropriately so that's
what we're going to look at
today all right so let's imagine we have
some boxes right so it's like Deal or No
Deal uh sort of like that but that vag
is going to break down pretty quickly so
I'm going to draw some boxes I could
have pre-drawn these but where would be
the fun in that now you don't know what
numbers are in these boxes it could be
any number on Earth any number on Earth
is that thing any number but we do know
they're in order so the lowest number is
here and the highest number is over here
let's say they're introduced just for
the sake of me not giving myself a
headache right now I want you to find
out if the number 17 is in one of these
boxes that's the thing you need to do
this is what binary search is for but
just searching in general right so maybe
you've got a database with a bunch of
IDs and you need to look up a specific
person's ID or you need to find out
anyone who's born on a certain date
right looking through data to find
something is very very common this is
just one way of doing it so that's the
rules right the boxes are ordered M how
do we find this as quickly as possible
the naive approach will be we start on
the left right let's just just open this
box let's not do anything clever open
the first box the first box is two so
it's not
so we've failed badly but we are at
least slightly closer to the goal
because now we only have this many boxes
to open so let's think about that how
much easier have we made this problem uh
well it was what was it eight boxes
you've made yeah whatever seven boxes
now right we made it one box easier one
it's not trivial right so if we the best
case from now is 17's here we open the
box 17 job done right the worst case is
we look through all of these boxes one
at a time and said 17 isn't in there
right or it's right at the end or
something like this I'd think I'd divide
and conquer I'd go yeah I think you
should divide and conquer right so if we
know them in order we can start looking
a bit like you would look through a
phone book right you'd open a phone book
you don't open a phone book on the first
page and start come on I mean I know
that their surname begins with zed but
I've started so I'm going to finish this
right so let's open up a box around here
right in the middle I've chosen an even
number of boxes but so let's just sort
of do this one and and now okay so we
open this up and it's not 17 let's say
it's 16 which is awkward but sure okay
so now what have we learned how much
easier have we made this problem well we
know now that given this is in order
that 17 cannot appear here and here
right let's presume we haven't opened
two it can't appear here either it has
to be in one of these or not in the in
the set of boxes at all so how much
easier is our problem you've Haled it
I've halved our problem yeah but problem
is double as easy you know in some in
some sense um so now let's fall back to
our rubber we'll just open this one and
then this one and this one and this one
or we can repeat this process that would
be much better 17 you would assume it is
going to be the next one less is another
16 that's true actually 16 is a terrible
terrible example for that reason let's
make that 10 right fixed fixed um delete
all that bit of video right this is 10
so we don't know now no the point the
point is we're trying to make a general
algorithm right we don't know what this
number is all we know is 17 was bigger
than it so now we're in this half
yeah so we jump halfway so let's say
this one right and we say okay is this
bigger or smaller than 17 well it's
104 so we now need to go to this half
right but it's and we're harving every
time we're harving our problem every
time and we look in here is it 17 and no
let's say it's 16 oh 16's come back and
so no 17 isn't in this set of boxes now
you know you might be thinking I should
have done this ahead of time and then
you know come my example better um but
the point is that we can make this much
much easier by divide and conquering
right if we know these are in order
which to be fair is a big a big ask
sometimes depending on the data we can
zero in on our um on our Target number
as quickly as possible so how much
easier is this well what was the running
time for the linear search which is just
going like this right well it's going to
take exactly how long the number of
boxes is right or you know we might get
lucky halfway we might not but you know
in the worst case it's going to need all
of the boxes to be searched and we're
not going to find the number we're after
so we call that o of n right so that's
saying but roughly speaking the amount
of time a linear search will take is
directly related to how many items we
have right now this is not very many
items but if you've got gigabytes worth
of data that's a lot of searching to do
so how much
easier is this when we're doing binary
search so we're dividing by two and
we're dividing by two again and then
we're dividing by two again well
actually it's O log to base 2 of N and
what that's basically saying is that as
n increases our problem doesn't increase
at the same rate right if n doubles our
problem only gets one harder so suppose
we have a billion numbers right and it's
this hard if we have two billion numbers
we just have one extra step because we
have to do that first divide to get down
to a billion numbers right so it's so
much more efficient and it scales so
much better scaling really I think in
these kind of algorithms is what's
important it doesn't matter how long
this takes for two numbers right because
you just look at them it's it's it's not
a huge deal but when you've got billions
or or or you know even more of numbers
that you've got to look through being
able to do an algorithm like this is
going to be much much better right um so
how would we program something like this
well what we need to know is we need to
be able to basically be able to
calculate the midpoint of where we are
right and so the first time that's EAS
easy cuz it's just the length of this
array divided by two right but actually
we want to be able to generalize this a
little bit so it' be helpful if we have
a couple of variables that um that
determine where we are so let me draw
out some more boxes and we'll we'll do
it fresh speed this bit up okay they got
less good as they went through any we
need to think about how we're going to
implement binary search right we're
looking for some number let's say it's X
in this list and we don't want to open
the first one and then the second one
that's linear search we want to divide
and conquer we want to go halfway now
the first iteration would be quite easy
we just take the length of this list
divided by two but actually we want a
more General solution depending on which
bit of this problem we're solving and
how many iterations we've run already so
let's define a couple of variables let's
say the left is the leftmost Box we're
considering and the right is the
rightmost Box we're considering and we
initialize them at being the first
element and the last element of of our
list or our array so then we can
calculate the midpoint the first one
we're going to look in as m is equal to
l+
R / two and then that might be depending
on 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12 13 it's
actually I think it's this one no it's
not it's it's halfway between these two
if L plus r does that mean l as in the
number one one plus yeah or zero
depending on whether your indexing is uh
is it depends see what I mean yeah yeah
so um so but we we you know in we don't
want to arrive halfway between two
elements so we'll just do the floor
function here so we'll round down to the
nearest integer or discard all the extra
bits and so we're going to end up I
think here right I'm not actually
counting now I'm just going to guess so
this is M now we open this box or we
look in the array or we read the
database entry or whatever it is we're
doing and we find out that X is not
equal to M so we haven't finished and we
find out that X is bigger which means
that X must be in this region here if
it's in this list at all we also now
know that this is not this it's not
these it's not these and it's not this
one and we also know it's not this one
because we just looked and we haven't
had to look at any of those so we' saved
a huge amount of time so the next
iteration what we need to do is we need
to move our left hand side over to here
so that we're now looking in this region
so I'm going to change color
controversial uh and I'm going to say
okay L is now not there excuse me L is
there n no we've already looked at that
one we don't need to do that so then R
is stays where it is right and then we
create a new m so we do m is equal to l
plus r / 2 and that ends up here so
let's do our new M and we look in this
one and we say Okay X is actually
smaller than this so what we've done
there is we've discarded this one this
one this one and this one so we can now
move new color fancy right uh L stays
there R moves to
here right and we do L plus r / two
which is actually going to mean that m
is the same one here right like this I
should have done that above um and so we
look in this one and if M
matches then again we're finished if not
we're going to have to go this way and
so on and what will happen eventually is
you'll you'll do this for however many
items you have and eventually L andr
will swap places because you'll move one
of them this way or something like this
if L is greater than r or something like
that then you're finished right and you
haven't found it now hopefully you do
find it but it depends on it depends on
the problem um so you know hopefully you
can see this is much much faster than um
than doing a linear search and actually
it's not very difficult to implement
because you've just got L you've got the
array you've got R and M that's pretty
much oh and X that's it right there's
only a few variables there's actually
only a few lines of code so let's write
that up in Python and see how it goes
all right so let's look at this I've
just I've Just Whipped up this algorithm
it's very very straightforward we have a
function called binary search that's a
success as far as I can tell it takes a
list which I've called LST and an a
which is our variable we're searching
for right so I've changed the name of
the variable just to confuse matters we
set our left to be zero because in
Python zero is the first element of an
array and we set the right to be the
length of the array minus one which is
the last element of the array and then
we have our Loop so we basically say
okay while L is smaller than or equal to
r or less than or equal to R we're going
to repeat we're going to calculate our
new M which is L + r / 2 and here I've
used the double slash to do an integer
division so basically will automatically
discard any fractional component then we
say okay is a greater than the element
of M in which case we set the left hand
side to be M plus one or we say okay is
a less than the element of M in which
case we set the right hand side to be n
minus one or have we found the right
number in which case just return true
right I'm not actually returning the
number from the list I'm just returning
true or false right and that's the
entire um the entire function if we get
to the
end and there are and and L andr swap
places we just return false because the
number wasn't in the array right so
let's have a got let see how much faster
this is so I'm going to run python here
so I'm going to python minus I bin. Pi
which is my function well how big is the
array you're looking at then well I'm
looking at an array that is not so big
that my computer dies that was what I
was really aiming for so I've chosen the
array 2 billion no sorry no I think 100
million I think 100 million is Right 2
billion might be pushing my laptop a bit
far because there's a lot of overhead um
you know in the variables and things
like it just seems to be taking up quite
a lot of ram um I'm not overly overly
confident uh I minus I uh Bin do PI
right so we run this and now it's loaded
up my function so I can say uh
binary
search and it will show me I've got a
function there so I can look at it so
now let's create a new
list um and a big one so what I'm going
to do I'm going to import numpy because
that's a good way of generating large
list of numbers so import
numpy it's a new list LST is equal to
numpy do random. Rand int So Random
integer right let's not do decimals um
and how big do we want how many random
do we want and how what's the maximum
value they can take well let's make them
two they're somewhere between Z and 2
billion right in terms of the numbers
and let's say size is equal to 10
million right so
10 million so that'll be an array of 10
million items that might be any number
between yeah zero and two billion two
billion yeah so there'll be a little bit
of repetition but not a lot right and
will that come out sorted um no no so um
let's let's let's let's push it out a
bit let's make it 100 million right one
more okay then I'm going to copy this to
a list right there may be a better way
of doing this I I don't know what it is
um this could take just just take a
little minute it won't take as long to
do this as it will to to sort it right
where we might actually go and get a
coffee first so now we're going to say
LST is equal to sorted LST right and
then we're going to just just relax for
a little bit cuz we've got we've got
some time to wait now actually this is
quite an interesting
point part of the interesting thing
about binary search is that we we're
assuming the data is already sorted now
sometimes that will not be the case and
sometimes sorting it is the real problem
bit you see and so actually I think one
of the really interesting things about
things like binary search is you didn't
shouldn't just use it all the time you
use it when you're doing more lookups
than you are sorting right so if you you
know maybe you sort your data at the
beginning of the day for some reason and
then you just do lots and lots of
lookups throughout the day makes a lot
of sense to do something like this right
whereas if you only ever want to look up
one value you might as well just find it
and and not why you see what I mean so I
think actually it's rather than just
learning all these algorithms I think
it's just interesting as if you're going
to be a software developer to think
about when just to be aware of when you
should be using certain algorithms
whether it's appropriate yeah because
you know there's a lot of people are you
know can you program this kind of tree
from scratch well probably not actually
I've forgotten how to do it but what I
can tell is that you know when I'm using
a hash set or a a list I know roughly
which algorithm would be the most
appropriate in terms of efficiency for a
specific task and I think that's a
really helpful bit of knowledge to have
because if you just use the default one
you'll often find it's quite slow as
we're about to find out we're still
sorting the list by the way to be fair
this is a lot of numbers how much RAM am
I using oh it could be worse it's only 5
gig um but I couldn't mult that would be
that would suggest I couldn't multiply
my data sets size by another 10 although
okay sorted that's good right so if we
type Len of list right it's 100 million
right there's a lot of zeros here I'm
trying to it's 100 million we can for
example select the millionth element to
the millionth and 10th element right so
we could say uh list index from a
million
to to there right so that's the all all
the numbers in this array from a million
to a million 10 position um and one of
them is uh 17 there 17's not there would
you believe um now um there will be a
little bit of repetition in this array
because some of the random numbers would
have turned out the same but we're not
going to worry about that today so if we
want to find out whether a numbers in
this array all we need to do in Python
is use the in keyword right so I could
say is 17 in
LST and we sit here for a bit while it
looks through every single number
and it's not going to be in there false
right now why did that take so long
right because you know 17 is going to
appear right near the beginning right
well it's because python doesn't know
that this is a sorted list right there's
no reason for python to know so it has
to use a generic algorithm like a linear
search to solve this problem right so if
17 had been in it would have returned
very very quickly because it would have
hit it right at the beginning but it
didn't right so if I look at if I search
for this number that I can already see
is in the Le so if I say 1
72 627 in List It returns almost
immediately because it just goes a
million in finds it stops right
so sometimes you get lucky with this
sometimes you don't but if you're just
using the in keyword and your list is
very very long you're actually just
doing a really inefficient linear search
right so this is one of those times
where you might think okay maybe this is
a time when I need to find a slightly
better algorithm to do this so let's use
our binary search and see if we can find
some stuff in here so for example binary
search so now you're going to use that
script that you've written yeah so I'm
I'm using the function I'm I'm writing
I'm going to pass it the list I'm going
to pass it 17 and it immediately returns
false because it's just gone like this
doing a b search it's taken um log to
base two of 10 million right steps right
which
is 23 right so 23 steps and it got there
yeah log to base two of of 10 million is
roughly 20 22 23 steps so it would have
got there I mean if you found the number
on the first go it might take fewer than
that but on you know in the worst case
it's 23 steps whereas the worst case for
finding 17 in this list of a linear
search is 10 m uh million steps right
sorry 100 million steps right 10 times
worse so it's really bad
so you know this is a really really
powerful argument that gets used all the
time and and you know extensions of this
where you have binary trees and you're
searching through binary trees is a
similar principle and the idea is that
you've structured your data in such a
way like we've sorted it here that you
can zero in on your target much much
more quickly and so it's really really
useful what what I can't understand
about this is is why is there a green
pen all over my hand like have you got
like a video of me just Penning my own
hand cuz that's every time I finish a
computer file I've drawn all over myself
and I don't understand when the video
I've done this but anyway it's it's
that's a a smaller side